okay thanks
um
i when i submitted that abstract i left
it pretty vague because i figured then i
could talk about whatever i felt like
when i got here and orlean gave a great
talk uh yesterday that is close to some
of the stuff i hadn't planned to talk
about so that
i kind of changed the title a little bit
here but you know people say oh i want
to pick your brain on something well i'm
thinking about using multi-arm bandits
to pick a whole bunch of brains
for information and that's what i'm
going to talk about and this is a
picture of our lab back in madison
okay so really i'm going to keep it
pretty simple i want once you want to
give you one kind of motivating kind of
application to think about and that is
sort of a contest type of problem so
suppose you have n items they could be n
beers for example in a beer contest and
papers at a conference you want to
choose the best student paper
or end resumes you're trying to hire
somebody you want to find the best
person for a position and you have a
pool and i'm really thinking more about
large pools of people uh who could judge
these items
and the question is if we want to find
the
item out of this set of n that is most
preferred by all the judges
how should we allocate the judging
and they're sort of at some very simple
level two ways you might think about
doing it first of all you could say well
let's just somehow uniformly allocate
our judging resource over all of the
items and then collect the ratings and
see which one gets the highest rating
out of all those uh
that were judged
or rather than just sort of that uniform
distribution you might say well maybe we
can start
collecting ratings getting judges to
look at items and as we get a little bit
of a sense about what's going on maybe
we might see some of the beers are
really really not liked at all
and but there's others that people are
giving higher ratings maybe we want to
stop
asking judges to taste those yicky lucky
beers and focus them more on the beers
that might be winners or maybe we want
to have some of our judges look at
certain papers more than others because
certain papers seem like they're really
in contention for that best paper award
okay so that would be an adaptive
allocation
so this is uh i'm going to sort of
formulate this problem as a multi-armed
bandit and i just want to set up a
little of the notation it's pretty
simple so we have n arms so each arm
corresponds to one of the items
we have expected ratings or scores that
we get for each item
and i'm going to order them from the
highest score to the lowest expected
score
like this so mew1 is going to be the
top item and its
expected score or rating is mu one
and then i have the rest of them and and
i'm going to assume that there's a
distinct winner namely that mew1
is bigger than mewtwo and and all the
others strictly larger so that there's
no issue of a tie we'll just avoid that
for you okay
we don't know the order of course but
i'm going to keep them in this order
just so that when i show pictures and so
forth we'll just always think of arm one
as being the best arm but of course we
would never know that going into this
contest problem
what we can do to get information about
these means we want to basically learn
that mu1 is the largest we can get
random ratings from judges and so the
ratings are going to be so xi is a
rating for item i from judge j and we're
assuming those are coming from a
probability distribution who's
parameterized by that mean expect
expected uh
uh rating ui
and uh the i don't know why i have two
of these here that's funny at any rate
the judges are gonna assume our id so
we're just getting basically iid
samples of mu i
okay you can think of those as noisy
versions of miui so that's x i j is a
noisy sample of uh from this
distribution p mu p mu i
and then the natural thing we would do
is collect a bunch of these
uh ratings or scores and average them
and that would give us an empirical
estimate of that
uh of the different uh score expected
scores and the idea then of course is
use these empirical averages to choose i
hat
so that i hat not equal to one which is
the correct winner that we're trying to
find is uh happening with small
probability some delta which is a small
number
okay so we want to be correct with
probability one minus delta in picking
that the first item is the one that
should be the winner is that pretty
clear
good
uh
so then you know the way you start doing
this usually is you would say well what
can we say about our empirical means so
we're going to assume that these are
sub-gaussian distributions and then we
can you know have a little concentration
inequality saying that the empirical
means are concentrating around the true
means so it looks something like this
for some constant c
and you know this is just you know could
be churn off if things were bernoulli or
huffing if they were bounded or it might
just be a gaussian tail bound if things
were gaussian but those are just all
special cases of this
and what that's really telling us is
that with probability at least one minus
delta for a particular arm and a
particular
number of judging say t
i can say that that true mean
is sandwiched between uh these two kind
of confidence limits that are defined in
terms of my empirical mean and then uh
this these confidence bounds things that
come from the
concentration inequality okay so that's
really simple stuff
so i just said for fixed i and fixed t
this is what we had but we kind of want
to have it not just for a particular
item but all the items simultaneously
ideally so then we're just going to
take delta and
change it to delta over n so we
effectively have a union bound over all
the items now i have
confidence intervals for all items
simultaneously at a particular number of
samples t
and then i also want to hold it for all
numbers of samples so maybe one sample
two sample three sample and so on and so
forth i don't i don't want to say i know
in advance how many samples i'm going to
take and so then i'll
also divide by 2t squared so i'll take
delta delta over this and that again i
can union bound everything and then i'll
have confidence
bounds that hold for all i and all t
okay
so
once you do that things are pretty easy
so first of all
let me uh
explain like something that you probably
would never think you would do but let
me just
talk about it just to kind of get
everybody going here
so let's think about non-adaptive what
would you do so non-adaptive again this
is like this uniform allocation of
judging
across all the items you just judge
every item an equal number of times so
we have equal confidence you know that
the confidence interval widths are equal
across all n items
and you're just going to keep sampling
every arm uniformly
until
you get to a situation situation like
this where one guy's confidence interval
is strictly above all the others then
you know without
any confusion at least up to this sort
of confidence level of delta that indeed
one is the winner
right
so that uh
that's what you could do if you that's
what you would do i guess with this
setup if you were being non-adaptive
about how you allocate the judges and
then you could say well when is that
going to happen well basically what it
means is that
the
confidence intervals have to be small
enough so that the
difference between the first and second
mean mu 1 minus mu 2 which i'll define
that gap as delta sub 2
you have to have that
the confidence intervals
or two of these guys be smaller than
that gap so this is one of my this is
like one side of a confidence interval
is what i have right here and i need
twice that and twice that again which
gives me this 4.
and so basically saying you have to take
enough samples so these confidence
intervals shrink enough so that they're
small relative to the gap between the
first and second best items
and if you just then invert that you can
see that the time it's going to take
is a constant times
or no more than a constant times the
inverse gap squared delta 2 to the minus
2 and then the log of n over delta delta
two to the minus two
and so that's how many samples per arm
are sufficient in this non-adaptive
setting to determine the best one with
confidence delta
and then if you just say how many total
samples would that be well i have to do
that for all n so i just have a factor
of n there
so that's non-adaptive that's not what
people would normally think to do that's
not really how you think about multi-arm
bandits so what would you do with an
adaptive scheme
and this is basically what's called
successive elimination it's an algorithm
that's been a while for around for a
while even dar at all we're the first to
maybe maybe the first to analyze it
and the idea is that well as soon as we
see this confidence interval save our
best
guy our upper confidence
bound is is if this guy's lower
confidence
limit is above the upper confidence
limits of some other arms we can just
safely discard them so you would
obviously you would not keep sampling
guys that you already know cannot be the
winner
and that's the idea you just get rid of
these and then you only focus
additional sampling on the ones that
remain and you just keep doing this
kicking guys out as soon as their upper
confidence limit
falls below the max lower confidence
bound
okay
and
using the same sort of reasoning that i
just had on the previous slide you would
say well when would the ith arm be
removed well
the number of samples you need ti is
going to be on the order of
the gap delta i to the minus two and the
gap delta is the gap between mu 1 and mu
i so that that's that gap between the
top arms expected reward
and the itharm and then you have the
same business here this log n over delta
delta i to the minus 2
and then the total samples would be a
summation of all those
tis
okay
so let me so this
this is a little bit better than what we
had in the non-adaptive thing and let me
just show you an example that kind of
illustrates this so
let's look at a case where
we have basically two good arms
one slightly better than the other and
in fact let's make the gap kind of small
shrinking with n let's say it's one over
the square root of n so those two are
pretty darn close and so you should
think we we ought to really pay most of
our attention most of our judging on
those two to tease out which one's truly
better if we want to
really give the paper award to the most
deserving paper
but all the other papers are are pretty
crummy it turns out so they're all
say their deltas their gaps are greater
than a constant maybe one
okay so in this case the non-adaptive
procedure that i said uniform allocation
of judging would be basically order n
squared
total
samples you'd have to collect versus
something like order n so there's a
you know potential this is an extreme
kind of artificial case but you can see
the gap between adaptive and
non-adaptive could be pretty large
okay
another thing you notice here is you
know we're getting this log n
uh because we're doing this union
bounding to get all these simultaneous
uh confidence intervals for every arm
and every time
and you could uh well these i'm sorry
these are just for
union bounding over all the arms and so
you could wonder is that really
necessary to do you have to suffer that
logged in
so um
i want to kind of think a little bit
about
what's really going on in this problem
this again it kind of relates a little
bit to what orleans talked about
yesterday but
suppose we were just looking at two arms
like we were just talking about those
best two arms in that that last example
and naturally what you would think about
doing is you would take the
uh
scores you're getting from those guys
and compare their empirical means or
equivalently just look at the sum of
these differences
and if that's
greater than zero then you're going to
decide one and if it's not you decide to
and so if the two
means were actually equal in case that
the gap then would be zero
and think about this maybe as just being
gaussian
variables here then you would just have
some zero mean random walk like this on
the other hand if the mean mu one is
really bigger than mu two then the delta
two is greater than zero and you're
gonna have some drift and so your random
block is gonna be a walk with a drift
okay
so let me let's see here so there's the
drift
and uh
what do we know about random blocks well
we kind of know that at least the zero
mean random block ought to stay
in a kind of envelope which is
given by the law of the iterated
logarithm
right
so this random walk the blue one
shouldn't kind of
you know morally speaking shouldn't come
outside of this square root of 2t log
log t which is the lil bound
okay
and
the idea then is to say well at some
point the drift is going to take you
outside this so probably then you would
think that if there was a drift your
your your
drifting random walk will
cross that lil bound and so the idea is
roughly to say how long is it going to
take well it's the the drift slope which
is your delta
times the time
and when does that equal this lil bound
which is the magenta curve i have there
and if you work that out then it sort of
suggests that that's going to happen
kind of around time
delta to the minus 2 log log delta to
the minus 2. so now we're seeing
first of all we still have that inverse
gap squared that's the delta to the
minus 2 but then instead of log of the
delta minus 2 we have log log so we have
a double log that's an improvement right
there okay
and so what i want you to sort of
think then is that really
maybe our
sample complexity is something more like
this so it's the sum of the inverse gap
squared and then a log log term and no n
at all no no union bound over over all n
arms that's sort of what we would hope
for
and we think this is probably about as
good as you can do
it certainly we know it's as good as you
can do when you just have two arms
what are you trying to achieve you're
comparing here uh an almost sure bound
which is a lot with a very good
logarithm against the mean of another
one so right
so what i'm trying what
so what i'm just trying to say is that
if you
squint
oh good
this is what you might hope for this is
not a you want with probability more
than one half that one of them can be
distinct from the other i mean what what
is the
ah yeah you want to eventually with
probability or confidence at least one
minus delta you want to decide that
correctly that mu 1 is the best one so
it's the same problem as before down
here
same criteria in this fixed confidence
setting as opposed to a fixed budget
which we also heard about yesterday
and then i'm sort of saying based on
this kind of hand wavy stuff here this
is what i hope to get to
all right so
it turns out
that
you know
it's not terribly difficult to get a
kind of finite sample version of the lil
and you can get confidence intervals
that then look like this so you have
this log log thing in there okay
and uh this holds for all t but just for
a given i it's not a unit it's not a
uniform bound for all i it's just
uniform for all t
okay
and we're going to use a slightly
different strategy it's still confidence
bound based but it's called a ucb style
algorithm upper confidence bound
algorithm and the idea is that we have
now what i'll call these lil confidence
intervals and the way
a ucb algorithm works is it said says
every time you're going to take a new
sample
look at which arm has the
greatest upper confidence bound so the
greatest one of these upper guys and
sample that one to try to pull it down
okay
and what that roughly says is that
you'll you're equalizing all these upper
confidence intervals
right and so the picture
would look something like this and what
it's telling us is that
you're going to be sampling the arms
that have large means much more
frequently than these the larger the
confidence interval the fewer samples
you've taken
and so it sort of automatically focuses
your sampling biases it towards
potential winners
okay so um
i'm not going to
go into too much of the analysis of the
algorithm i just kind of want to give
you a hint of what's going on though
is that eventually somehow
it's very very hard to push
the upper
confidence bound of the top arm
down unless you keep sampling it again
and again and again and again because
he's got a gap between the first and
then the next best guy and you end up
basically this algorithm will focus all
of its sampling attention on that best
arm
and so
our analysis is actually to sort of
explain that and quantify it a little
bit more so there's sort of two key
steps the first is
to show that the sub-optimal arms using
this ucb algorithm will be sampled
finitely many times and in fact
you can get
a a bound like this that with high
probability
the total number of samples you take
from arms two and larger is going to be
bounded by something like what we were
just looking for what we were hoping for
before in terms of that total complexity
bound
and
another thing the next thing you do is
you show that no sub-optimal arm
is going to be sampled more than some
constant number of times
the total number of samples collected
from all the arms so this is like all
the other arms some constant you're
saying you're never sampling any one of
the sub-optimal arms more than a
constant times all the other samples
you've taken
and if you put these two things together
basically the idea is that at the end of
the day the only arm that won't satisfy
this at some point
the optimal arm won't and then you stop
that's your stopping criterion
um
the key at a very very loose high level
is that rather than trying to control
all of the arms and their confidence
intervals individually which we could
have done with that successive
elimination style algorithm that's what
we were doing we're just kind of looking
at controlling
averages of things
and this averaging
it gets kind of subtle in the details
but basically that's the the why it
works you don't ever have to take a
union bound over arms because you're
doing this averaging
the only one that you're really
guaranteeing control over is that top
arm and then the other things you're
controlling are averages
okay
and so this is here's a there's a movie
of what happens this is a simulation and
you can see that equalizing the upper
confidence bounds and you can see that
eventually i just keep banging on that
top guy over and over that's exactly
what happens
and then the theorem that i say here is
basically saying as long as the arms are
sub-gaussian then you do get this
inverse gap squared log log
kind of sample complexity and we we
don't have any reason to believe that it
could be improved from that
okay so that's one thing i wanted to
explain is that clear to everybody
good
so
one of the reasons we set out to do this
is because
we work with a bunch of cognitive
scientists psychologists and and other
people and they have real problems where
they want to collect information from
people and they want to do it really
efficiently
and when we started implementing some
banded algorithms for these types of
tasks
we noticed that uh
some of the albums that were really nice
in theory
uh were very very yeah the constants
were super huge and this this kind of
algorithm is actually something we would
probably
use it's like the constants aren't so
bad
and uh i think they're practical
algorithms so we're sort of trying to
take some of the theory
which sometimes is you can get some
bounds that look good if you ignore
constants but then they end up being
kind of crummy algorithms for the scale
of problems that some of the
psychologists are looking at like if you
only have 100 items and you have a
thousand people on mechanical turk
answering questions you might not be in
a regime where you can kill off really
huge constants like 3 000 out in front
of your bounds
so
another thing that they're really
interested in this kind of taking me to
the second kind of idea i wanted to
convey today is that they they're often
not interested in getting ratings or
scores from people because it's hard to
calibrate different people and so
instead they'll just try to look at
comparative judgments
okay so what they'll do is they'll
basically give people a choice a forced
choice between two items and say which
one do you prefer or which one's better
in some sense
okay that's a four paired comparison
force choice kind of experiment very
common in psychology so for example
rather than asking you to rate beer a or
beer b i might just say here are two
beers take a taste of each which one do
you like better okay
so
you can formalize this also as a bandit
type problem it goes by the name of
dueling bandits which comes from this
paper by you at all in
and the basic idea is this so you have a
bunch of probabilities p i j that's the
probability that arm i
is preferred to arm j
okay
and then you get samples of those you
know basically bernoulli samples from
that probability you see outcomes of
people
making these comparisons that compare
item i to j and they either say better
or one's better or the other so here's
one or zero
now things get a little trickier here in
this case uh there there isn't a clear
way to say what you mean by the winner
in this kind of situation
uh and so there are a lot of different
criteria uh there's a condorcet winner
which is basically saying
if there's any
item or arm
that
is probably better
when compared to any other individual
arm you'd like to pick that one that's
the condorcet winner it
generally would not exist so that's one
problem with the condorcet criterion
it's really nice
if a condor say winner exists but it
doesn't always exist another option is
board a
winner that's what i'm going to focus on
and let me just kind of explain what the
board id is so the border idea is that
we'll define
the score
of each arm
or the expected score or rating to be
just the
average probability when i compare item
i
to all other arms so i just take that
average
okay so what this is saying is you'd
like to then pick
the item or arm that has the largest
score
on average or largest probability on
average compared to all the other arms
so it's going to win
more duels on average
okay
when paired with a randomly chosen other
arm
and so
uh
that's the border score
we can simulate samples from an arm by
just basically
saying a sample from arm i
is you take arm i you dual it with some
other arm j
where j is selected uniformly at random
over the remaining arms
and that gives you a
a sample
from this distribution
okay
so you do it with a random other guy and
that simulates a sample from this
that's a noisy version of the score
and so once you have that board f
reduction
of the problem set up we're back
in the
situation where we can just work with
the muse
we know how to get samples that on
average 10 to the muse and so all the
algorithms that we had before apply so
that
lil stuff and the ucb algorithm we can
just use it now
okay so that's one of the nice
attractive features of the border
approach is that it
simply reduces back to a normal kind of
best arm bandit problem
so we thought well
is that is that the end of the story you
just do this border reduction and now we
can deal with dueling bandits at least
under this border criterion just using
all the other things we already know
about and we started to wonder if
there's if that's really true is it is
this the best we could do if we want to
find the board a winner which would
again be the guy that has the largest
score here which i'm going to call mu 1
again
is this the best strategy to do this
reduction and just go from there so to
think about that i'm just going to kind
of look at two examples okay so these
are two different matrices of these pijs
these dueling probabilities
and
basically in both cases
the first two arms which are the first
two columns here
are
the two top guys
and one is the best
the same in both cases we have large
probabilities
uh in in those two columns and rows
three quarters roughly
uh
but there's a difference here so what so
why is one better than two well he's
just slightly better
than two when dueled against arm three
so he's got a little epsilon
edge
on arm one
he's also got
sort of a an edge on our arm sorry he's
got an edge on arm too he's got an edge
on arm two in this case too but now that
epsilon rather being concentrated just
in one duel is sort of spread out over a
bunch of duals
okay and so somehow
our thinking was that this would make
things
this situation here would be easier
because maybe if we can figure out who
are the top guys and then just
focus uh our dueling on those and and if
it's revealed which one's better just by
one dual or arm three in that case maybe
we can capitalize on that structure and
so it turns out
you can if you know the probabilities up
to a permutation so let's just so say i
gave you all those probabilities i know
that there is this three quarters plus
epsilon somewhere in here i just don't
know exactly which arm it is and so
forth
uh then how could we capitalize on that
information i'll show you in a second
but the
what we're going to see is that the
total number of samples required in this
case to find the border winner is sort
of like order n and the total number of
samples in this case is going to be like
order n squared so there's a big
difference
even though
if you look at the board of scores which
would just be averaging across the rows
here say
the border scores of the first two arms
are the same in both cases so both these
p's basically end up with the same board
of scores which are those muse but one
problem's much easier than the other is
what i'm trying to say
so let me just kind of step through how
we would what what you might do here if
you knew this matrix up to a permutation
you know that's the problem you're dealt
with you just don't know which arm is
which
so what you might do is you'd first
dual
each arm with
logged in randomly chosen other arms
okay
and what that's going to do is that's
going to give you enough information to
basically determine that arms one and
two are the best because these guys are
going to sort of look like
uh their their border score is going to
be more like three quarters and all the
other guys are going to have a border
score that's more like one half so
you've got a pretty big gap between
those border scores you do a small
number of random duels and you can home
in on these two guys are the only real
contenders
once you found that out now you know
that these two guys are these columns
you just don't know where the three
quarters plus epsilon is is it arm three
is it arm four so on and so forth so
what you're going to do then is you'll
dual arms one and two
against
each other arm
something like one over epsilon squared
times and that gives you enough of a
kind of epsilon accurate estimate
of all of those other sort of partial
border squares if you will to deduce
that indeed this one
is bigger than this one and i can
finally then decide
that uh arm one is better than arm two
and that's what gives me
this calculation right here i have to do
that with every arm so i have to do that
n times
okay so that's where that order n comes
now
if we tried to do the same thing with
the other case
we would again say dual
each arm with login other arms chosen
uniformly at random that would again
tell us that
one of these two is the best
and now you could say well once i know
that i know i could just compare
these guys to any other arm say arm
three because they're all going to be
the same story
just slightly better for arm one in
every case but then to get the level of
accuracy i'd need to distinguish these
two i have epsilon over n i square that
i get n squared over epsilon squared
sorry yeah
one minute okay good i'm almost done
so
that's just sort of an uh argument for
kind of like an upper bound but you can
use fano's inequality and show this as a
lower bound too
okay so some problems are easier than
others what's the key idea somehow
there's some sparsity lurking around in
here most of the duals are not
informative for distinguishing the big
the top two here whereas all of them are
sort of informative in this other case
and so we want to exploit that sparsity
uh and this is
the idea i have one minute so i'll just
say that
again the board of gaps the board of
scores we could do what we were doing
before uh with the lil but we want to
know could we adapt to sparsity
the long story short is not agnostically
and if you use some of orleans uh very
nice work you can actually prove a lower
bound that if you want
an algorithm that's going to give you
this delta confidence
for all p matrices
regardless of whether they're sparse or
not you're not able to adapt to sparsity
you really have to suffer something very
close to this you can't really improve
using sparsity okay so really you can't
be adaptive to sparsity agnostically but
if you start off with an assumption of
sparsity you can do better so what's the
idea let's suppose that the best arm is
differentiated by any sub-optimal arm by
a small subset of say at most k
duals
then the idea is basically like that
successive elimination i was talking
about but instead of just eliminating
arms you also eliminate duels as you go
and you start to focus in on what are
those really discriminating duels
and if you do that you can prove some
nice results but basically you can prove
you're able to improve on that basic
border reduction
under the sparsity assumption and this
is just simulating for
that p1 matrix that we were just looking
at this is using this what we call
sparse border algorithm the slope is one
so n to the one basically linear growth
versus n squared that's the growth if
you use that lil algorithm the border
reduction i spoke of
and then this is just showing you that
it actually works on some data where we
simulated this process so that's it i'll
stop there here are the students kevin's
here he's sort of the lead on a lot of
this research so if you have questions
you can talk to him matt was another
students who meets a student in
sebastian bubeck at microsoft research
thanks